[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv soixante dix huit
l'émission ne pas manquer si vous êtes
un amoureux du sport local
c'est parti pour le sommaire un cyclisme
un championnat de cyclo cross était
organisée ce dimanche sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
plus de 500 cyclistes ont participé à ce
rendez-vous à huis clos
reportage à suivre golfe coup de
projecteur sur la nationale golfweek un
rendez vous sur la petite balle blanche
qui sont organisés du 1er au 3 avril au
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines avec au programme un salon des
compétitions des démonstrations l'un des
organisateurs charles-henri bacheliers
sera avec nous dans quelques instants
voile louis burton et bureau vallée ont
officiellement racheté le bateau
l'occitane en provence d'armel tripon
pour plus de 4 millions de roanne imoca
dernière génération avec folle qui a
terminé 11e du dernier vendée globe
la réaction de louis burton dans cette
émission l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on prend tout de suite la direction de
l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines la structure a accueilli ce
dimanche les championnats de france
cyclo cross la compétition a réuni les
catégories à cadets juniors et masters
des images de patrick jacques de dixmude
un montage de marine de la barbe et et
matteo au luxe euros la fédération
française de cyclisme a réussi son pari
les championnats de france cadets
juniors et masters sont pu se tenir ce
dimanche 21 février sur l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
malgré le contexte sanitaire et
l'annulation de la plupart des courses
en france
quand on a compris qu'on ne pourrait pas
le faire tenir en même temps que le
championnat de france élite qui était
tout début janvier à pontchâteau et on
avait pris l'engagement de vraiment tout
faire pour essayer d'organiser un
championnat c'est avec beaucoup de
bonheur qu'on a reçu l'autorisation de
la préfecture il ya huit jours pour
pouvoir tenir effectivement ce
championnat l'événement s'est tenu à
huis clos avec un protocole sanitaire
une jauge maximale de 500 personnes en
simultané était également mise en place
des règles strictes qui n'ont pas
contrarié les 550 coureurs venus des
quatre coins de la france les cyclistes
présents n'ont pas boudé leur plaisir de
recourir après cette saison de
cyclo-cross bouleversé je suis partie un
cross de la saison
donc parce que ça a été compliqué c'est
vrai que là ça va être la salle de ça va
être la seule c'est la seule compétition
pour l'instant à laquelle on a eu droit
donc
c'était un objectif c'est un objectif de
l'année ça a été annulée reportée donc
bah voilà on est au rendez vous ce que
je garderai c'est simplement quand les
jeunes hier passer à côté de moi le long
de la ligne nous simplement le fait de
dire merci et sourire on avait déjà
gagnés dans ce week-end sur le plan
sportif c'est 550 courant du se dépasser
pour atteindre leur objectif une boucle
de 2 7 km autour du centre équestre de
l'île de loisirs avait été imaginé ils
apportent vraiment tout ce qui est le
dans cette discipline vous avez de la
technique vous avez des parties
roulantes vd partout il faut de la force
il faut reconnaître la trajectoire
il y avait des parties où il faut porter
du vélo ici on surligne l'agir de 50 ans
on est vraiment sur le territoire du
cyclo cross le succès rencontré par cet
événement malgré la crise sanitaire les
organisateurs espèrent désormais
organiser un championnat de france élite
de cyclo cross à l'horizon 2024
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir un autre rendez
vous ce sera au mois d'avril au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le site va accueillir une nationale
golfweek du 1er au 3 avril pour nous
parler de ce rendez vous inédit nous
avons avec nous par visio l'un des
organisateurs charles-henri bacheliers
bonsoir bonsoir
alors déjà première question qu'est ce
que la nationale golfweek expliquer
alors la nationale golfweek c'est la
volonté de deux passionnés de golf et
d'événementiel anton robin et de faire
un produit qui plaisent à tous les
golfeurs qui soit un rendez-vous qui lie
toutes les dimensions du jeu avec un
tournoi professionnel en association
c'est à pro est un amateur et surtout
les meilleurs joueurs français et on a
eu la possibilité de faire cet événement
au golf national grâce à pascal grizot
qui était le monsieur ryder cup que vous
avez bien suivi à l'époque avec tv soit
118 et qui est le nouveau président de
la fédération française de golf
récemment élu et qui veut
insuffler au golf un nouveau souffle le
sac c'est sûr les jeunes montrer que
c'est un sport extraordinaire que ce
soit pour des questions de développement
de 2,2 soit de santé de également de
plaisir parce que c'est un jeu ce n'est
pas qu'un sport sur lequel on peut
vraiment s'amuser d'où le tournoi pro
qui sera donc en place au moment de cet
événement qui sera un 6 gré c'est-à-dire
au lieu d'être
le sacro saint jehan stroke sur 18 trous
et plusieurs journées ce sera un match
play sur syrte
six trous le 1 le 2 le 15 le 16 de 17 et
18 les six plus beaux trous de
l'albatros ce parcours mythique où a eu
lieu la ryder cup et dans le cadre de
cet événement donc les meilleurs joueurs
français qui vont se retrouver sa
société on va également avoir la chance
dans cet événement d'avoir des
conférences des moments où les
professionnels être disponibles pour
leurs fans pour leur montrer ce qu'ils
savent faire le mieux pour leur répondre
à leurs questions pour faire des séries
ou des dédicaces
il ya également des pratiques aussi et
toutes les nouveautés est également une
partie exposition où on pourra voir
toutes les nouveautés du marché du golf
et c'est plutôt pour les spécialistes du
golfe où c'est vraiment de fonds publics
alors c'est justement l'objectif de ce2
de cet événement c'est que c'est fait
pour tout le monde
voilà c'est fait pour ce qu'ils sont des
absolus fans qui veulent venir voir les
grands champions ce sont ceux que c'est
fait pour ceux qui veulent juste se dire
mais ça fait longtemps que j'avais envie
de passer la porte je ne vais pas aller
tout seul dans un golf là il y aura les
équipes de la fédération et de tous les
gestionnaires de parcours français qui
seront là pour accueillir les débutants
les néophytes qui ont vite si m il y
aura aussi pour ceux qui sont ni des
fous ni des débutants sont ni des fous
de jeu de golf donc des passionnés
absolue ni des débutants donc 95% des
golfeurs français
il y aura également tout ce qui leur
permettra d'améliorer leur jeu de
pouvoir prévoir des voyages de pouvoir
prévoir d'aller découvrir de nouveaux
parcours
ailleurs en france de pouvoir trouver de
nouveaux équipements de pouvoir trouver
un partenaire de tours noir tout ce qui
peut faire que ils vivront plus
intensément le boeuf
l'objectif c'est vraiment de
démocratiser le golf c'est bien ça alors
le but
en effet c'est de faire du bien au golf
et de montrer et c'est un sport génial
un jeu ludique sur lesquels on peut
venir à tout âge et doux qu'on vienne
sortir des clichés du côté il faut être
patron du cac 40 ou d'une grande
entreprise américaine pour y jouer comme
l'ancien président notion de sept états
unis qui s'est beaucoup montré récemment
voilà donc oui le golf est un sport
démocratique fait pour tous il ya plus
de 700 installations parcours 18 trous 9
trous practice en france peu près 7 136
je crois si les derniers chiffres que
j'ai sont bons c'est à dire que en
moyenne y en a sept par département 7 à
8 par département donc on peut jouer au
boeuf n'importe où en france quel que
soit son niveau social et c'est quelque
chose d'absolument extraordinaire et on
va essayer de le prouver avec cet
événement qui sera quelques rats toutes
les personnes qui voudront bien faire
l'effort de vouloir y venir il y avait
ce salon du golf à mantes-la-jolie 1 ces
dernières années est ce que le fait que
ça soit sur le golf national
haute de la dernière ryder cup en 2018
est ce que ça apporte encore peut être
un peu plus de poids peut être à
l'événement alors c'est c'est évident
car c'est devenu déjà c'est un très beau
parcours qui accueille l'open de france
depuis plusieurs années avec des grands
noms du golf mondiaux européens qui ont
gagné mais en plus depuis le passage de
la ryder cup est une extraordinaire fête
populaire que ça a été et le golf
national a pris une autre dimension et
c'est une chance inouïe de pouvoir le
faire
dans ce lieu là car c'est la fédération
française de ball sous l'impulsion de
son nouveau président qui a décidé de
mettre le golf national et les équipes
de la fédération de golf national au
service d'un événement qui se veut
fédérateur qui veut faire du bien aux
golfeurs français sont bien sympas dans
les yvelines donc c'est quand même super
non c'est chou si je comprends bien
c'est bien pascal grizot qui est venu
vous chercher c'est ça alors pascal a eu
l'idée géniale
évidemment qui est lui qui voue une
génération française de golf quand je le
rappelle c'est ça c'est ça et qui ai eu
l'idée de demander à antoine qui
portèrent un projet de tournoi ce fameux
nationale match play qui sera la tête
d'affiché de la nationale golfique avec
les meilleurs golfeurs français de se
rapprocher des versicolor nouveau
propriétaire du salon du golf pour unir
nos forces et faire ce produit là alors
vous pensez à tirer combien de personnes
sur cet événement on ne sait pas encore
si les jeux seront adaptés ou pas est-ce
que vous fixez les objets tout turkson
avec attention votre sujet précédent à
500 personnes jours pour la jauge
l'événement n'a pas de sens est retenu
donc nous espérons avoir une jauge d'ici
là deux entre 2000 et 4000 personnes
voilà sachant que l'événement a lieu sur
presque 20 hectares ça peut sembler
beaucoup de monde mais 20 ha c'est plus
grand que la plupart des villes
françaises donc c'est sur un espace très
grand donc il n'y aura pas de de
concentration forte de populations après
nous sommes malheureusement comme klein
d'organisateurs d'événements culturels
et sportifs soumis totalement à
l'évolution de l'épidémie de kogi d' 19
qui casse les pieds de plein de français
voilà donc nous travaillons dur nous
sommes déterminés et nous ferons face au
principe de réalité et dans le cas où il
nous faudrait
et surseoir à l'événement de toute façon
nous serons en 2022 parce qu'il ya une
adhésion très forte du de l'industrie du
monde du golf
parce que c'est vraiment un produit
magnifique et qui réjouira vraiment tout
le monde
dernière question est ce que ça sera
payant cet événement oui alors c'est à
moitié prix pour les habitants de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est à dire qu'en fait à moitié prix ce
sera 15 euros pour deux personnes pour
un couple alors que normalement c'est 15
euros par personne et pour les licenciés
ce sera 10 euros au lieu de 15 euros
donc ceux qui ont une licence de la
fédération française de golf et c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 18 ans parce
que le but c'est de faire venir des
jeunes et plein de jeunes qui est la
cause majeure de la politique la
nouvelle politique de pascal grizot
merci à vous charles-henri bacheliers ou
vous souhaite bon courage pour
l'organisation alors je rappelle
événement devrait être organisée du 1er
au 3 avril au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
on va maintenant parler de voix la
nouvelle est tombée à ceux à mardi à
midi libinois louis burton troisième du
dernier vendée globe en janvier dernier
annoncé continuer l'aventuré avec bureau
vallée au minimum jusqu'en 2026 autre
annonce importante le rachat du bateau
l'occitane en provence d'armel tripon
pour plus de 4 millions d'euros
un imoca dernière génération avec folle
qui a terminé 11e du dernier vendée
globe on écoute le skipper lors de sa
conférence de presse cette vitesse ce
concept fait rêver et on est on est on
est persuadé que à la condition de
savoir préserver la structure lorsque
lorsque le lamer sera pas sera pas au
rendez vous pour attaquer on est
persuadé que ce sont des vins que c'est
un bateau
du coup ce bureau vallée 3 qui est qui
nous permettra d'aller chercher des
podiums et peut-être en tout cas
j'espère ça va être mon objectif la
victoire
louis burton a également annoncé lors de
ce rendez-vous vouloir remporter le
vendée globe en 2024
en football vous le savez le paris saint
germain battu en 8e de finale aller de
la ligue des champions le fc à barcelone
sur son terrain mardi dernier
pour composer son groupe l'entraîneur
mauricio pochettino avait fait appel un
joli minois et doit michu le joueur de
17 ans est passé par les clubs du chéné
de versailles avant d'intégrer le paris
saint germain l'international
u17 a signé son premier contrat
professionnel l'été dernier avec le club
de la capitale un contrat qui ira
jusqu'en 2023 le genre ce n'est
finalement pas entré en jeu lors de ce
match
il est resté sur le banc il jouera
peut-être le match retour le 10 mars
prochain contre barcelone toujours en
football le comité exécutif de la
fédération française de football a
validé la semaine dernière la reprise du
championnat de nationale 2 après l'avis
positif du ministère des sports
un protocole a sanitaire sera mise en
place sur les mêmes conditions que la
coupe de france avec notamment des tests
pcr avant les rencontres dans les
yvelines les clubs de versailles et de
poissy pourront donc reprendre la
compétition dès le 13 mars nous avons
avec nous via écran interposé
le président de poissy olivier ses v ux
bonsoir bonsoir
alors qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
reprise le 13 mars prochain
mais à écouter dans un premier temps je
me réjouis effectivement qu'on puisse
retrouver les terrains
je pense que ça c'est vraiment le
premier sentiment qui prédomine
maintenant effectivement contenu comme
vous l'avez récemment pressé
précédemment dit il y aura des des
protocoles médicaux donc coûté j'attends
qui peut on a eu quelques informations
depuis vendredi donc on va effectivement
être obligés de se tester 24 heures il
ya tout un protocole
écoutez nous on accepte évidemment cette
décision
néanmoins vous comprendrez que on aura
certainement en nationale 2 aujourd'hui
dans notre groupe en l'occurrence
des équipes parce que vous savez très
bien qu'on nationale 2 il ya des équipes
des réserves professionnelles qui ont eu
la possibilité de d'avoir des exercices
très technique et très professionnelle
nous nous avions nous avions des règles
et ces règles étaient juste de courir
des petits ateliers mais on n'a pas pu
depuis le 1er décembre avoir un esprit
de groupe
donc ça va être un petit peu compliqué
mais on va s'adapter puisque on est des
compétiteurs
alors je rappelle le protocole
sanitaires très strictes un test pcr
obligatoire 24 heures avant le match
présence d'un médecin le jour du match
pour contrôler les tests pcr référent
commises dans chaque club liens étroits
avec la rs ce n'est pas trop lourd pour
un club comme poissy ou même comme un
club en général de nationale 2 écoutez
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que on a
pas d'autre solution
donc on doit s'adapter nous avons au
sein de notre club et au comité de
direction en l'occurrence un des
responsables du chu de poissy donc dès
vendredi dès vendredi soir nous nous
sommes appelés afin de regarder
intelligemment et comme on pouvait on
pouvait appréhender ce qui va se passer
je pense que depuis vendredi on a
énormément travaillé effectivement c'est
un peu compliqué pourquoi quand on va
être à la maison on fera un test le
vendredi pour jouer samedi on ne sait
pas encore à quelle heure visiblement
c'est toujours 18 heures néanmoins quand
on va partir en province
on a deux déplacements et surtout celui
à qui est assez loin saint malo
comment les choses vont s'orienter je
pense que c'est une discussion en
interne mais mais vous savez c'est comme
ce que l'on vit actuellement c'est pas
qu'au football
donc voilà on a la chance d'avoir des
garçons comme je dis aux garçons on a
vous avez la chance d'être en bonne
santé par rapport à d'autres il faut
accepter toutes ces conditions qui vont
être mises en place et on va s'adapter
on n'a pas d'autre solution mais écoutez
moi je vois ça
déjà une reprise le reste
ça vient après on verra bien comment les
choses s'oriente sportivement néanmoins
en tout cas par rapport au protocole
médical
on se tient prêt et on s'organisera en
conséquence il fallait reprendre
obligatoirement pense aux footballeurs
mais également aux partenaires à tout le
monde à tout un club
alors ça c'est une très bonne question
merci de le signaler
effectivement on a parfois des
protocoles avec des avec des partenaires
qui nous disent bon écoutez en fonction
d'eux en fonction de d hospitalité des
matchs joués
il est possible que demain dans l'absolu
et certaines entreprises et je peux le
comprendre
étant déjà chefs d'entreprises en
difficulté dans l'événement eh bien
écoutez c'est ouais c'est 2000 mal j'ai
envie de vous dire ces deux mâles
effectivement il faut de la visibilité
donc on va essayer de on va essayer de
déjà de garder ses sponsors puisque ça
va pas être facile
et effectivement le le fait de reprendre
la compétition
ben va mettre va mettre en avant ses
partenaires qui sont essentielles
aujourd'hui pour la vie d'un club
les joueurs seront prêts le 13 mars 13
mars prochain on va écouter et très
honnêtement je me réjouis et je remercie
d'ailleurs le préfet monsieur le maire
karl olive qui nous ont permis dès le
1er décembre de pouvoir bénéficier des
infrastructures
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle les
garçons sont entraînés mais je réitère
mes propos on n'a pas pu faire des
petits jeux donc là c'est un peu
compliqué effectivement alors la chance
que l'on a c'est que on va pouvoir faire
deux matches amicaux qu'on a déjà
programmé voyez on est on a pris les
devants pour se préparer tactiquement
puisque c'est jamais facile de reprendre
la compétition
on compte quand elle est
traditionnellement ce sont les vacances
c'est une chose là effectivement depuis
le 1er décembre
aucune compétition pas beaucoup de
petits jeux techniques tactiques
donc c'est un peu compliqué néanmoins
avec ses ces deux matches amicaux
j'espère que j'espère que les garçons
seront prêts il y aura un nouveau format
du coup pour pour terminer cette saison
le nouveau format justement du
championnat consiste à terminer la phase
des matches aller plus à constituer une
poule d'accession et une de maintien
pour les matchs retour chaque poule est
constitué de huit clubs
en fonction du classement arrêté à
l'issue des matches aller le nombre d
accession aidée relégation reste quant à
lui identique c'est une bonne formule
olivier c'est luc alors écoutez on va
pas se mentir on va pas se mentir
l' exploit si dernier de son groupe
donc effectivement pour nous le
challenge c'est d'aller récupérer
quelques points même si les matches qui
nous sont proposés ont lâché le premier
ça va être assez compliqué
néanmoins pas d'autre solution pour moi
dans un premier temps est-ce que la m3
va redémarrer
ça c'est un vrai sujet ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui quand on voit à la lecture
peut-être des fermetures de nice
certaines régions les week-ends imaginez
qui est un cluster de nouveau là ça sera
pas possible
est-ce que la n3 va repartir c'est vrai
3 repart bah écoutez ça sera un format
mais si elle ne reprend pas
ça veut dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
descente alors égoïstement je vais vous
dire oui je souhaiterais effectivement
qu'il n'y ait pas de descendre cette
année mais le championnat quand même été
tronquée quoi qu'il arrive donc je vais
pas me plaindre
si on en est là on est tous responsables
moi le premier parce que je suis
président néanmoins j'ai envie de vous
dire ça va être une situation
effectivement très compliqué ce on va
jouer des matches de coupe de france
c'est très clairement va jouer des
matches de coupe de france en espérant
qu'on puisse en puisse avoir quelques
quelques points nous permettons pourquoi
pas parce que de toute façon nous sommes
des compétiteurs
moi aussi je dis à mes garçons que on va
de l'avant et pourquoi pas être dans la
première moitié de terrain
un boîtier de classement pardon et puis
après on verra
écoutez pour l'instant on n'a pas
beaucoup d'informations effectivement il
ya des choses qui se disent mais j'ai
rien de concret sur les descentes en
tout cas sur les montées c'est normal je
pense que parce que la nationale est au
dessus il ya un classement pour monter
et de descendre puisque il continua à
s'entraîner et à jouer mais par rapport
à la nationale 3 dites vous bien que si
la nationale 3 reprend pas comment
voulez vous qu'on fasse descendre des
clubs donc après une autre question
est-ce que des équipes ont joué le jeu
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui j'ai pas
d'informations autre que ce qui était
écrit on n'a jamais été sollicité pour
échanger sur le sujet
jusqu'à présent dernière question est ce
que c'est vraiment la dernière chance
pour terminer le championnat je pense
ont regardé le calendrier ci mafia les
restes tous tous les matches retour donc
quoi qu'il arrive comme on les fera pas
et qui effectivement vous l'avez dit ça
ce sera des play-offs
bah écoutez c'est la dernière chance si
d'aventuré un week-end étaient encore
bloqués compte tenu de la situation
sanitaire
il est évident que là je pense que ça
serait une saison blanche
bon pour l'amour du football et pour les
joueurs pour un tas de choses pour les
sponsors et vous l'avez très bien dit
c'est très très bien de reprendre
néanmoins il ya quand même quelques
interrogations sur cette fin de saison
c'est écrit pour l'instant c'est sur
papier néanmoins compte tenu de la
situation je vous dis une fois de plus
si on fait un match qu on nous arrête le
week end après je pense que là stop
terminer fin de l'histoire et en
repartira sur une saison je l'espère
pour tout le monde savait ce qui nous
importe à tous et vous le premier c'est
que la santé revienne et qu'on reprenne
le monde d'avant même si les choses
changeront certainement à presque vide
merci olivier c'est les yeux qu'est
d'être dans cette émission sera
évidemment présent pour la reprise du
championnat à poissy ce sera donc le 13
mars prochain
à noter dans vos agendas il y aura du
volley ball ce week-end dans le
championnat élite le club de conflans
andrésy jouy se déplacera sur le terrain
de marseille pour le compte de la 6e
journée du championnat élite c'est la
rencontre est programmée salle vallier
dans le 4e arrondissement de la cité
phocéenne
conflans espère pouvoir jouer cette
rencontre l'équipe était à l'arrêt forcé
ces dernières semaines à cause de cas de
kobe 19
cette rencontre est importante pour les
yvelinois pour terminer dans le haut du
classement ils sont pour l'instant à 6e
on termine ce magazine par un petit défi
celui de thomas ce violent le danois
capitaine de l'équipe européenne pendant
la dernière ryder cup en 2018 à saint
quentin en yvelines s'est amusé avec un
club une balle et une tasse chez lui le
golfeur vainqueur dans les yvelines n'a
rien perdu de son talent et de sa
précision au regard des
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
il